what must it feel like for these tiny
feet to be in socks this after wandering
a Colombian jungle for 40 days she and
her siblings all alone
in bogota's Military Hospital every care
is taken
the world awaits to hear how they
survived
they told us about the little dog that
got lost it had been accompanying them
but they don't know where it went
they've said a bit about how they feel
they don't talk very much and they're
weak but they want to play
the toys are ready but it'll take some
time before the children are
there's plenty of support waiting
outside the hospital
volunteers with presents
and an overwhelmed relative Keen to take
them home
I've just seen my grandchildren they're
alive but a little bit down I know
they're in good hands in hospital and I
know things will be okay
he goes on to ask the children be left
alone now mindful perhaps of the trauma
they've been through
they were on a plane traveling from San
Jose del guaviare to ARA quora on the
1st of May the pilot issued a Mayday
alert when the aircraft's single engine
failed
two weeks later the plane's wreckage was
found more than a hundred miles south
three bodies including that of the
children's Mother were also found
the Army searched a three-mile radius of
this dense jungle
they dropped food boxes traced footsteps
and even used loudspeakers to play a
message from the children's grandma
their rescue came after 40 days recovery
will probably take much longer
Sadia Chowdhury Sky News